mike chapel will open the discussion for
peyton manning and i know he's been
waiting for this all his life
uh i'll just say man
i would drop my uh
i would drop my laptop but i'm not gonna
do that so just pretend that you see me
dropping the mic
into the discussion
thank you
unless there's anybody who wants to say
anything on peyton manning
we'll move on
anyone
mike thanks for that presentation i wish
they all were that short good job
some would say
that the hall of fame should consist
only
of those individuals of the ones where
you need no discussion i hear yes i hear
you that you shouldn't have to if you
have to debate it for two hours the
person shouldn't be in now it's gotten a
little loose
that cuts against
the i've become jaded in my advancing
age
it's a museum that they want people to
go visit right
and they want to have a big event they
want to have a big celebration every
year so you have to have new busts you
have to have five six seven eight new
busts every year to justify the party
that injects all this money into canton
as people come to town and the more who
get in the more parties held in canton
the more families come to canton the
more fans come to canton it's a business
folks it's that's just what it is it's a
museum that b that turns canton into the
center place of the sports universe for
a day or two every august so it can't
just be the no-brainers
unfortunately it should be it should
just be
okay peyton manning yeah tom brady yeah
aaron rodgers yeah but the problem is
you'd have one guy most years some years
you wouldn't even have a ceremony there
wouldn't be anybody who meets that bar
yeah you're probably right it would be
hard i i i i would think you know i
one thing i don't like is the minimum
number that that's the one thing i guess
i i mean what why can't we have a year
of two or three guys get in something
like that i just explained it i know
it's a business but to me it does take
away from you know the the great aura of
the hall of fame yeah it does and i
don't want it to get watered down i mean
i know it has no you know direct
affiliation with the nfl but it's still
very special in the grand scheme of
football and everything like that
and uh i just i worry about that i do
that that's just
that
i worry about the dumbest things because
i will have been dead for hundreds of
years before it ever becomes a problem
but if you keep putting in five a year
eventually you're gonna have so many
busts what the hell are you gonna do
with them well what's gonna be so
special about going everywhere going who
the hell are all these guys and where
the hell is the guy i wanted to see and
all that i mean i don't know yeah those
are things i think about too
i i mean what was the the the comment
that josh allen made to you the other
day about there was a guy named mickey
mantle like you know i mean the world
keeps spinning right and people are
gonna forget you have new generations
that's not part of their experience it's
not part of their knowledge that's not a
name they're aware of so i i look i i
get it i understand why they do it they
want people to go to the museum at some
point they're gonna need a big ass
museum to fit all those busts but again
neither you know i will be around to
have to worry about that that's gonna be
somebody else's problem way down the
road but all right with this group right
here like first off the the guys that
are just locks like you're we're going
to talk about right that we just go okay
there are hall of famers that's it
you're talking i mean that's peyton
manning right
that's charles woodson for me it's those
two for sure as slam dunks like yes
you're in calvin johnson probably the
next guy out there
no it's not first balance didn't play
long enough to be first back okay okay i
i i can't justify first ballot okay i
can hear that i don't know if i totally
agree with it i understand the argument
it is a nine year career
okay and it was like whoa we gotta
change our defense with this guy on the
football field now the next guys this is
a tough one
you know i'm of course biased to guys
like rondae barbara who i saw in person
and saw all the great things he could do
within that tampa defense the tampa two
defense how awesome versatile no
weakness to his game i love him of
course i'm going to sing his praises big
time the other guy on there they're just
from as a fan and somebody i look at it
allen fannika come on it's one of the
greatest guards of all time somebody's
got to put him in i know he's an old
lineman it's got to happen at some point
richard seymour i'm going to piggyback
off of brady though that's the next one
like hey everybody out there have you
guys watched coleas campbell the last 10
years of the nfl career you know do you
guys know everybody's slam dunk all of
it richard seymour is kaleus campbell
before that you know and before we put
notice on guys who mess up plays and
ruin plays that don't get stats but are
ruining plays and other people are
getting the tackles that that for me
you're talking about one of the great
teams in the history of the nfl
and the best player on that defense or
the two best were ty law
richard seymour
okay and they just you know
seymour deserves to be in that's one i
would stump for hard
you're speaking to one of the big
challenges for the voters which is all
different shapes and sizes and types of
football players thrown into the same
bucket
and some guys can get overlooked when
they don't have the dazzling statistics
when they don't have that obvious set of
credentials that get them in right and
there is a certain order that the voters
try to impose on it i remember and i
can't remember who it was but there was
an offensive lineman who got in one year
and i asked a voter why did he get in
and the response was there's so many
other great players coming up in the
next four or five years if he doesn't
get in now he's never getting in right
to me that's not a reason to play that's
not a hall you're exactly right i agree
that's your that's that's politics
that's bull crap that's then that's the
problem with this process a little in
general is there's some players and
people and it gets political and they
get you know newspaper people and other
media members to get behind them to push
their own narrative and a lot and we've
seen it works it sways people to to to
make it happen whatever so uh that is
something that you know has to be
balanced within this conversation
i i said at the moment eli manning
retired the campaign to get eli in the
hall of fame led by peyton and archie
already has begun and if you think it
hasn't you're naive and he's getting in
eventually maybe not first ballot but
he's getting in because his name's
manning and because of his
accomplishments but if it was any other
name
it would be on the fence very on the
fence maybe right but he's getting in
because of his name and because he's
going to have the weight of his brother
payton pushing those voters
that's a very real element here it's one
of the reasons why i want nothing to do
with it frankly they don't want anything
to do with me so it's easier for me to
say this i don't want anything to do
with that process uh because um i would
end up pissing everyone off sorry london
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports